all right here we go i like it ready  yeah wait for it  action  it's an example of opposites of track we  couldn't be more different i got a  vibranium off  and i can fly  there are definitely days where i feel  like he's gonna kill me what's going on  in that cyborg brain of yours gear's  turning oh they're malfunctioning  they're on fire god i hate him  he's like you know when you have a fly  in your house and it just won't go away  but we have a very good dynamic uh  absolutely not come on i'm telling you  we got we have fun with each other and  that carries into these characters  so what's our plan  so no plan  great  i'm so excited because it's exhilarating  it's a throwback to all those bloody  comedy action movies you just don't know  if they're gonna kill each other or not  hello girl kick your eyes  [Music]